انفجار في البنتاغون
لحظه انها صوره مزيفه فبركها الذكاء
الاصطناعي لكنها تظهر مفارقه تكنولوجيه في
عالم تويتر لاننا شرها يمتلك اشاره زرقاء
ما يعني حسابا موثقا علق حساب بلومبرج لكن
المستخدمين تداولوها قبل الحذف خاصه وانهم
صدقوها ولوهله حتى البورصه الامريكيه هوت
لوقت وجيز ثم انهلوا على ملك تويتر كيف
جعل العلامه الزرقاء ذات ثمانيه دولارات
لمن يدفعها لا لمن يستحق التوثيق اي انه
جعل تويتر ارضا خصبه لاخبار كاذبه تؤدي
الى فوضى عارمه خبراء التقنيه قالوا انهم
حتى لو علموا بان علامه التوثيق الزرقاء
لم تعد تشير الى الشرعيه فمن الصعب كسر
عاده بصريه اكتسبها المغردون على مدار 15
عاما
دمار نفته الدفاع الامريكيه لكن رماده
وبحسب الخبراء جعل من تويتر منصه لم تعد
قابله للتصديق
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات